PowerPoint or any other program like that...
...is one of the big problems that people have.
So often I've heard people say, "This is my presentation,"...
...and they show me this big stack of slides.
That's not your presentation.
You are the presentation.
Those are just visual aids.
When we work with people at Benjamin Ball Associates...
...we often take away their PowerPoint to start with,...
...get them to deliver their presentation, just them talking,...
...and then afterwards, then we introduce the visual aids.
So if you've got a speech coming up, or a talk or a presentation coming up,...
...the worst thing you can do is switch on PowerPoint.
Get a blank sheet of paper, plan what you're going to say,...
...and then the very last thing you do is think,...
..."What visual aids can I use to help me get my point across?"
If you want an example of really bad use of PowerPoint, just go to any conference.
Just sit there for a while,...
...and very quickly you will see how not to do it.
And if you're lucky you might get one or two speakers in a day who got it right.
Your job, if you're trying to do something, is to emulate that one or two.
Don't fall into the trap of producing lots of PowerPoint.